eine Warnung vorweg in diesem Podcast
wird recht detailliert der Umgang mit
einer Leiche geschildert denjenigen
denen solche Beschreibungen zu nahe
gehen raten wir vom Hören ab
hallo mein Name ist Sky Duo und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall
moin und ich bin Natalie Strauß ich bin
Radiomoderatorin aus Hamburg und begrüße
euch zu unserer heutigen Folge der Fall
den wir heute besprechen der liegt noch
gar nicht so lange zurück und fanden
mitten in meiner Heimatstadt ich bin an
dieser Straße sogar eine Zeitlang
andauernd vorbeigefahren das ist echt
ein bisschen gruselig und warum ich
seitdem immer so einen kleinen Schauer
bekommen wenn jemand Whisky Cola trinkt
das erfahrt ihr auf jeden Fall später
aber erstmal zu The Voice Mirko Kasimir
keiner entführt uns besser in die Welt
des to crime als du liebe Natalie vielen
Dank ich fühle mich extrem geschmeichelt
auch von meiner Seite ein freundliches
Hallo und lieben Gruß an alle Hörerinnen
und Hörer die genauso gespannt wie wir
auf den nächsten Fall gewartet haben
heute geht es darum wie eine
wunderschöne Liebe durch sucht und
Exzess zum Horror werden kann geschehen
2016 in Hamburg Barmbek
um die Geschichte zu erzählen fange ich
aber viel früher an
es ist der Sommer 1988
wir befinden uns in Ahrenshoop in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern die frische Brise
der Ostsee streicht über die sanften
Klippen des kleinen Örtchens am Darß vom
Spazierweg aus kann man über Mondblumen
runter an den Strand sehen
der 21 Jahre alte Reno schlendert mit
der 19 Jahre alten Silke den Weg entlang
sie sind so vertieft in ihr Gespräch
dass sie von der Schönheit der Natur
kaum etwas mitbekommen
beeilt euch ihr Turteltäubchen ruft
deine Freundin von Walter Frauen den
beiden zu
Silke wird rot kicherheit und rennt dem
anderen Mädchen zum Strand hinterher
Reno bei altzig und holt schnell auf
kurz werfen sich Silke und er noch einen
Blick zu und zaghaftes Lächeln
dann setzen sie sich zu ihren Freunden
auf die Handtücher auf den Sand
der Tag verfliegt im Nu die jungen Leute
lachen viel trinken Bier und die Mädels
sollen sich oben ohne
[Musik]
Renault merkt wie er jetzt auch rot wird
er traut sich kaum Silke anzusehen sie
ist so wunderschön
das graue Alltagsleben der DDR wird für
eine kurze Zeit vergessen und der Urlaub
auf der idyllischen halbinselkette
zwischen Hamburg und Berlin genossen
Reno und Silke lernen sich damals im
Sommer 1988 kennen verlieren sich dann
aber erstmal für lange Zeit aus den
Augen Silke wird mit 27 Jahren Mutter
einer Tochter die Beziehung zum
Kindsvater wenn es überhaupt eine
richtige Beziehung gegeben hat die hält
nicht ob sie auch nach dem Sommerurlaub
1988 weiter an Renault denken musste das
wissen wir nicht
Reno hat sie jedenfalls nie vergessen
und so machte sich 2012 auf die Suche
nach ihr
wo lebt das schöne Mädchen von damals
wohl heute
Social Media sei Dank kann man
heutzutage meist ziemlich einfach
Menschen wiederfinden
Reno g findet Silke m tatsächlich auf
Facebook und schreibt sie an Silke
antwortet die beiden tauschen
Nachrichten aus
aus dem anfänglichen schreiben wird mehr
die beiden verlieben sich nach 25 Jahren
neu ineinander und beschließen den
nächsten Schritt zu wagen
Silke zieht aus Berlin zu Reno nach
Hamburg hier leben die beiden Verliebten
in der tischbeinstraße im Stadtteil
Barmbek fußläufig zum Hamburger
Stadtpark ein schönes Wohnviertel das
schnell wächst viel wird neu gebaut es
zieht immer mehr Familien und junge
Leute in die Gegend
Silke und Reno leben in einem für
Hamburg typischen Rotklinker
Mehrfamilienhaus im hochpartei mit
kleinem Balkon und Gemeinschaftsgarten
das klingt doch echt zu schön um wahr zu
sein die Beziehung beginnt harmonisch
und sich auch mit viel Liebe und
Begeisterung füreinander
hier scheinen allerdings zwei Menschen
aufeinander zu treffen die beide große
Probleme haben der Alkohol ist
vermutlich eins davon und mit der Zeit
kippt die Stimmung
sie trinken viel miteinander zu viel
zudem nimmt Silke einiges an
Medikamenten denn sie leidet zum einen
und der Epilepsie zum anderen ist er
eine Form des Borderline-Syndroms
attestiert worden die Beziehung zwischen
Silke und Reno wird zunehmend toxischer
die Streitigkeiten werden schlimmer
immer heftiger mittlerweile muss die
Polizei öfter anrücken und schlichten
Mirko kommen wir zum Tat ab
der 8 mai 2016 ist ein Sonntag und nicht
irgendein Sonntag es ist Muttertag und
herrliches Wetter in Hamburg 24 Grad und
Sonnenschein
was genau an diesem Abend geschehen ist
können wir nur lückenhaftrekonstruieren
Silke hat den ganzen Tag auf den Anruf
ihrer 20-jährigen Tochter gewartet es
geht Dir nicht gut
wenigstens heute am Muttertag hätte sie
sich doch mal melden können
Reno und sie beginne zu trinken erst ein
paar Bierchen auf dem Balkon dazu
rauchen sie eine Zigarette nach der
anderen die Gespräche werden immer
hitziger
die Nachbarin von schräg oben schaut zum
Streitenden paar und schüttelt den Kopf
geht vor wieder Stress
Rede und Silke beschließen ihre
Diskussion nach drinnen zu verlegen
jetzt steigen Sie auf Whisky Cola aus
der Dose um
Renault wird später erzählen Silke habe
an diesem Tag so viel getrunken wie
selten zuvor
Alkohol bestimmt auf jeden Fall einen
großen Teil des Lebens von beiden Reno
erzählt später vor Gericht wenn wir
Alkohol getrunken haben rastete sie
plötzlich aus schmiss Sachen nach mir
ob es sich hier um eine einseitige
Aggression gehandelt hat oder sich
Renault nicht genauso wütend verhält
wenn er getrunken hat das werden wir
wohl nie erfahren an diesem Abend im Mai
eskalierte Streit der beiden aber völlig
die Tochter von Silke ruft ihre Mutter
zwar nicht am Muttertag an versucht es
aber in den kommenden Tagen immer wieder
vergeblich
niemand geht ans Telefon
vielleicht hat sie es auch bei Reno geh
versucht auch hier ohne Erfolg nach
einigen Tagen reicht es ihr und die
Sorge um ihre Mutter ist groß
die 20-jährige Tochter alarmiert die
Polizei
am Abend des 12 Mai gegen 19.30 klingelt
die Polizei an der Wohnung von Reno und
Silke
der Zustand des 49-Jährigen muss
furchtbar gewesen sein in den
vergangenen vier Tagen hat er sich in
einem ständigen Rausch Befunden ein Mix
aus Alkohol und Medikamenten hat ihn
durch die Tage gebracht
vielleicht war renaultier auch
erleichtert dass endlich jemand kommt
und ihm die Entscheidung wie es nun
weitergeht abgenommen hat
die Polizisten betreten die Wohnung
wir sind auf der Suche nach ihrer
Lebensgefährtin Silke sie wurde von
ihrer Tochter als vermisst gemeldet
weiter fragt der Beamte können Sie und
sagen wo sich die Frau befindet
Renault g soll geantwortet haben das
kann ich sie ist im Koffer unter dem
Küchentisch
der Beamte ist das ein Scherz
Renault geh nein nein ich habe sie
getötet und jetzt ist sie im Koffer
wow das klingt echt wie ein schlechter
Scherz es stellt sich aber heraus dass
Silke bereits seit vier Tagen tot ist
sie muss am späten Sonntagabend
gestorben sein zum gleichen Zeitpunkt
ändert Reno g sein whatsapp-status in
the end
renoge bestreitet allerdings dass diese
Statusmeldung mit dem Tod von Silke zu
tun hat er sagt aus ich habe mich so
gefreut auf das Black Sabbath Konzert
von der the end Tour am 8 juni in Berlin
ja ganz genau ist klar es glaubt
tatsächlich aber nimmt Reno g das
Geständnis dass er den Polizisten noch
am Tatort gemacht hat später zurück es
gibt also zwei Versionen vom todesabend
die in der renoge gestanden hat und die
in der alles abstreitet
beginnen wir mit der Version die Reno g
im Prozess erzählt
am Sonntagabend hat Silke so viel
getrunken wie selten zuvor sie ist
wütend auf ihre Tochter dass diese sich
nicht gemeldet hat
Reno geh sagt aus ich schätze mich als
Alkoholiker ein und Silke auch
wenn beide betrunken sind wird schnell
viel und heftig gestritten
renor wird es zu viel gegen 22 Uhr
beschließt er ins Bett zu gehen
Silke hat noch nicht genug sie will
weiter wach bleiben und will weiter
trinken
am nächsten Morgen findet Reno g seine
Lebensgefährtin in der Küche
ich sah sie dann in dem Küchenstuhl
sitzen überall war Blut daneben lag das
Messer da bin ich nervlich
zusammengebrochen
weiter gibt er an ich habe zum ersten
Mal einen toten Menschen gesehen und
dann waren da die großen Blutflecken ich
habe Silke berührt mir war klar dass sie
tot war sie war nicht mehr warm aber
auch nicht so kalt wie ein Stück Metall
ich hätte sofort die Polizei
benachrichtigen sollen aber ich ging in
den Supermarkt und holte mir eine
Flasche Whisky außerdem lag da noch das
Rezept für Silke Schlaf Tabletten die
Tabletten holte ich mir aus der Apotheke
zwei Tage verbringt er neben der Leiche
dann kann er den Anblick der Toten am
kirchentisch nicht mehr ertragen er
entfernt das Messer und deckt Silke mit
einem Tuch ab
dann kommt er auf einer absurde Lösung
in meiner Verrücktheit kam ich auf die
Idee mit dem Koffer wir hatten wenige
Monate zuvor mit dem Koffer Urlaub in
der Türkei gemacht ich brachte ihn in
die Wohnung von dem Zeitpunkt an weiß
ich nicht mehr was ich getan habe ich
bin froh dass ich mich nicht an die
Einzelheiten erinnern kann
das kann ich mir vorstellen wie krank
oder betrunken und benebelt kann man
bitte sein egal ob er Silke getötet hat
oder nicht wie kann man denn bitte seine
tote Freundin einfach da sitzen lassen
und zwei Tage weiterleben als wäre
nichts passiert
gleichzeitig kann ich mir auch
vorstellen dass es vielleicht eine Art
Trance oder Tunnel war und er wusste
sich vielleicht nicht zu helfen und dann
nach eben jenen zwei Tagen immer noch
keiner Einsicht oder die Idee die
Polizei zu rufen dann steckt er sie in
einem Koffer und was passiert wieder
zwei Tage nichts sein Versuch die Leiche
aus der Wohnung zu bekommen scheitert
übrigens weil der Griff das Koffers
abbricht ja stimmt mit diesem Typen
nicht
in meinem Wahn bin ich auf die scheiß
Idee gekommen dass sie nicht anfängt zu
riechen wenn ich sie in den Koffer lege
und nicht nur das er bestreut die Leiche
mit Waschpulver auch das soll den
Gestank übertünchen
seine Erklärung zur Todesursache
Silke muss Selbstmord begangen haben
durch ihre borderlinerkrankungen sei sie
psychisch sehr instabil gewesen
[Musik]
die Verteidigung gibt zu Protokoll das
Silke wohl nicht in Suizid Absicht aber
aus einer irrationalen psychischen
Ausnahmesituation heraus gehandelt habe
die Richterin glaubt davon kein Wort
die Staatsanwaltschaft trägt folgendes
vor
dem Angeklagten wird vorgeworfen in der
Nacht zum 9 mai dieses Jahres seiner
Lebensgefährtin mit der er aus
unbekanntem Grund in Streit geraten war
ein Messer mit einer Klingenlänge von ca
12 cm in das Herz gestochen zu haben
Silke m verstarb daraufhin innerhalb
weniger Sekunden
was muss bitte in Rhenus Kopf
vorgegangen sein also zuerst steht da
noch am Tatort direkt alles und dann
weiß der jede Schuld von sich dabei
spricht er einfach alles gegen ihn in
der Wohnung haben die Beamten sogar ein
Zettel gefunden auf dem Reno so etwas
geschrieben hat wie es ist leider alles
eskaliert Scheiße Alkohol scheiß
Medikamente sorry
also wenn das mal kein Schuldgeständnis
ist dann weiß ich auch nicht dazu auch
noch dieser WhatsApp Status wie end
quasi zur Tatzeit Reno hat den Tod
seiner Freundin nicht der Polizei
gemeldet und schließlich spontan standen
also bei dem lief scheinbar alles
durcheinander im Kopf wie kann er nur
denken dass er da in dieser Situation
ungestraft davon kommt
ja und so sieht das auch das Gericht wie
es tatsächlich abgelaufen ist das können
wir nur spekulieren hier eine mögliche
Version
der Muttertag 2016 beginnt harmonisch
mit einer Zigarette auf dem sonnigen
Balkon
aus einer Zigarette werden viele
aus dem morgendlichen Kaffee wird
Whiskey Cola
hier betrunkene die beiden werden desto
hitziger werden die Gespräche
wieder und wieder drehte sich um die
gleichen Themen Reno geh beteuert auch
nach der Tat immer wieder er und Silke
sein Seelenverwandte gewesen so schnell
wie ein Streit eskaliert sei so schnell
hätten sie sich auch immer wieder
beruhigt
tja nicht so am Abend des 8 Mai
vielleicht sind beide nachdem es auf dem
Balkon zu kalt geworden ist reingegangen
vielleicht hat eine winzige Kleinigkeit
Silke getriggert
da renoge sich nach der Tat mit neuem
Alkohol eingedeckt hat sind den beiden
am Abend womöglich die Drinks
ausgegangen wer soll jetzt noch mal los
zur Tankstelle und Nachschub besorgen
Silke sicherlich nicht sie ist kaputt
vom Tag wütend auf ihre Tochter und sie
gar nicht ein noch mal rauszugehen
Renault soll das mal schön machen
der denkt sich sag mal spinnst du hol
dir deinen scheiß doch selbst
der Streit eskaliert Silke setzt sich an
den Küchentisch und wirft eine leere
whiskydose nach Reno der steht gerade
vom Messerblock und tickt aus so nicht
Fräulein
im Rausch zieht er das nächstgelegene
Messer dreht sich um und sticht zu
die 12 cm lange Klinge geht direkt in
Sieges Herz
denkt sich renaultier lässt das Messer
fallen und rennt raus in Rage geht er im
Wohnzimmer auf und ab da steht doch noch
ein Bier schnell was nachkippen schnell
vergessen
auf einen Zettel kritzelt er die
Nachricht die die Polizei später finden
soll dann schmeißt er sich noch eine von
Silke Schlaftabletten rein ändert
vollkommenen benebelt seinen WhatsApp
Status und schläft ein
unfassbar renault will das alles
vergessen aber am nächsten Tag ja da
kommt das grausige Erwachen alles ist
wahr Silke ist tot
kein Wunder also das Reno jetzt wo er
nüchtern ist sind absolute Panik gerät
er entscheidet sich aber gegen den
vernünftigen Weg und stellt sich nicht
selbst der Polizei sondern holt sich mit
einem Rezept von Silke neue
Schlaftabletten und noch mehr Alkohol
nachdem das Urteil gefallen ist sagt
Renault gehe dann schlussendlich doch
noch aus
heute weiß ich was ich gemacht habe war
das allerletzte ich war in einem
wahnzustand völlig irre
das Urteil fällt im juni 2017
Reno g wird wegen Todschlags zu acht
Jahren Gefängnis verurteilt
aber jetzt kommt der ist schon nach vier
Monaten wieder frei erstmal
aus ganz absurden Gründen das Gericht
hat viel zu tun es dauert einfach zu
lange bis das Urteil rechtskräftig wird
heißt der zweite strafsenat des
Oberlandesgerichts hat den Haftbefehl
gegen den Verurteilten erstmal
aufgehoben
Zitat
weil der Angeklagte bis zur Rechtskraft
des Urteils als unschuldig gelte sei
eine Fahrtdauer der Untersuchungshaft
unverhältnismäßig so heißt es
Reno sitzt im Mai 2016 bis Oktober 2017
in U-Haft das sind 17 Monate in der
Regel darf die Untersuchungshaft aber
nicht länger als sechs Monate dauern
also kommt der erstmal trotz
Verurteilung wieder frei
den Herbst und die Weihnachtszeit kann
er noch mal in Freiheit genießen sofern
er sein Leben überhaupt noch genießen
kann nach allem was geschehen ist
im januar 2018 geht es dann schließlich
hinter Gitter
wo er sich bis heute befindet
Natalie das war mal ein Liebesdrama der
ganz besonderen Art das kannst du laut
sagen aber was das mit Liebe zu tun
haben soll ist mir tatsächlich
schleierhaft Mirko dieser Fall der lässt
mich einfach fassungslos zurück es ist
ja schon schrecklich genug dass jemand
seine Partnerin den Menschen den er
eigentlich angeblich liebt ermordet aber
dass er dann noch mit der Leiche
weiterlebt sie einen Koffer packt etwas
Pulver überschüttet ja und auch in
nächster Zeit anscheinend nicht vor hat
das zu ändern das macht mich einfach nur
fassungslos das ist gruselig das ist
ekelhaft boah
aber es ist nicht auch gleichzeitig
irgendwie total traurig und beängstigend
das auch offensichtlich niemand aus der
unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft aus der
Wohnung nebenan etwas mitbekommen hat ja
absolut eine Nachbarin hat gegenüber
Journalisten später ausgesagt dass sie
sich gewundert hat dass die beiden nicht
mehr rauchend auf dem Balkon zu sehen
waren aber sie dachte dass die
vielleicht im Urlaub sind
ich will diese Tat auf keinen Fall dem
Alkohol und Medikamentenmissbrauch
zuschieben aber es ist doch wirklich
schrecklich was das aus Menschen machen
kann
wir wissen alle dass es in so gut wie
jeder Beziehung mal zum Streit kommt und
manchmal wird er vielleicht auch sehr
laut und hitzig die Türen knallen und
und und und und und aber hoffentlich
nicht so schlimm dass die Polizei
gerufen werden muss und das macht mich
auch hier stutzig denn die beiden sind
ja scheinbar schon vorher recht
auffällig gewesen man kann nur immer
wieder appellieren wenn ihr sowas
mitbekommt dann bitte hört nicht einfach
weg egal ob in der eigenen Familie oder
der Nachbarschaft wenn Menschen mit
Problemen in Beziehungen sich scheinbar
aufs Übelste verletzen egal ob verbal
oder körperlich verständigt die Polizei
oder geht selbst ins Gespräch mit dem
Betroffenen wenn das möglich ist
ich hoffe einfach dass solche Taten
schon viel früher verhindert werden
können das hoffe ich auch an dieser
Stelle noch mal ein dickes Danke an
meine Nachbarschaft ja wir verstehen uns
da alle echt gut und ich weiß ich habe
auch ein paar Aufpasser im Haus das
mögen die einen mögen die anderen nicht
aber ich bin da echt ganz froh dass man
immer diese eine Nachbarin hat die hat
auf alles ein Auge da bin ich echt ganz
dankbar für ja danke auch dass ihr heute
wieder dabei wart und natürlich auch dir
mein lieber Mirko und ich hoffe dass ihr
alle das nächste Mal wieder dabei seid
bei Tatort Deutschland Spezial eure
Natalie und euer Mirko vielen Dank und
bis bald
[Musik]
den Mord an Silke m haben wir mit Bild
Welt und abendblattartikel nacherzählt
sowie Mopo und pressreader.com
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Haier Produktion Marvin schwarz